so leute also bürger ist da sieht doch
gut aus oder hey was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht's gut heute mit einem neuen
restaurant test jetzt wahrscheinlich am
lesen haben kerzen derzeit sehr oft
gemacht und es wird sich auch oft
gewünscht so alex du hast zwar
irgendwann lassen sich schon mal den
schlechtesten berger laden getestet
jedoch bitte auch mal den besten das
ding ist ich es wirklich sehr gerne
bürger und ich kenne auch viele läden
hier in köln und ich habe auch so 23
stamm leben wo ich halt immerhin gehe
die jetzt schon lecker sind auf jeden
fall und auch eine gute bewertung haben
habe ich alles gut und ich hätte das
video jetzt nicht unbedingt gemacht wenn
das einer von diesen läden wäre aber das
gute ist es gibt den laden der
stifthalter vor der glaube ich 4,9 oder
4,8 sterne auch bei über 200 rezensionen
und ich war doch nie deswegen check wir
denn heute mal zusammen ab und ich bin
mal gespannt ob mir da der bürger noch
besser schmeckt als bei anderen läden
hier weil die sind schon echt richtig
gut leute bevor wir uns allerdings die
rezension anschauen wollte ich euch noch
mal kurz was zeigen und zwar das ist
eben angekommen ich habe schon
ausprobiert und ich bin wirklich
fasziniert das ist in kooperation mit
robert so heißt dieses ding nämlich
offiziell ja hier stets auch ich habe
den schon alex wie junior getauft also
der heißt jetzt wirklich so in meiner
app und zwar ist das ein saugroboter der
wirklich komplett die ganze wohnung
scannt und überall sei ich habe den grat
schon überall gefallen lassen das ist
wirklich extrem sauer ich habe mich also
ich hätte das wirklich nicht gedacht
dass die dinger schon so gut
funktionieren weil der funktioniert
wirklich einwandfrei
man muss aufpassen dass ich so einen
jackenärmel auf dem boden liegt oder so
dann statt das ding automatisch und
schickt ja auch eine benachrichtigung
aufs handy
so sieht hier die app aus also da kann
man es sehen alex b junior dann kann man
hier drauf gehen und dann sieht man hier
den umriss der wohnung also der roboter
erstellt dann hier so eine karte und
sagt dann halt wirklich alles genau ab
also ich finde es auch so krass dass er
unter diesen tisch geht und so dann kann
er gleich auch hier ins bad fahren also
das macht ihr eigentlich alles
automatisch wenn er dann zum beispiel
hier über den teppich fährt erkennt er
automatisch dass es ein teppich ist und
sagt dann halt
noch mal stärker also ich finde es fast
täglich schon so weit wenn ihr das
genaue modell wissen wollte er bereit
ist
oder halt auf alex wie junior
wie kann man da noch so features dran
kommen wie zum beispiel das hier das ist
mit wisch funktion dann sogar also am
besten auf den boden
das muss ich später noch mal
ausprobieren aber ich würde sagen werden
der jetzt jahres aus mit dem erst mal
das essen weil das ist ja eigentlich der
sinn des heutigen videos und ich habe
auch echt grad also wir checken kur ist
die rezension ab sondern sie machen
vielleicht wieder
also leute wie eine bewertung von 4,8
sternen was halt wirklich das beste was
es gab nichts das besser ist ich muss
sagen ich habe vor auch noch nie was von
diesem laden gehört also normalerweise
so diese ich nenne jetzt mal hotspot
bürger leben in köln die kennt jeder so
sieht man dass die meisten ich wohne
jetzt schon über zwei jahre hier
deswegen man kennt die meisten so von
dem hab ich noch nie was gehört deswegen
bin ich mal umso mehr gespannt schauen
wir mal kurz in die rezension ein
wirklich fast alles nur fünf sterne ist
also mir ist aufgefallen es gibt sehr
viele fünf sterne und wertungen und dann
gibt es vereinzelt einstellung
bewertungen was dann halt zum beispiel
volle fünf sterne echter grund hat es
ist ja klar selbst wenn ich wollte
könnte ich nicht weniger als fünf sterne
geben super burger land weiter so wenig
top alles wird frisch und nach wünschen
sehr sehr freundlich zubereitet selten
so gute burger und pommes ist jedes mal
wieder super bedienung super bürger
alles selbst um frisch gemacht top-6 zum
fairen preis auch bei lieferung kommt
alles frisch und noch war man ja also
das meiste ist als positiv ich muss
jetzt ja gar nicht weiter vorlesen ich
würde sagen wir fahren jetzt einfach mal
hin und ich bin mal gespannt wie teuer
das ganze wird wie lecker ist schmeckt
und auch es mich überzeugt so leute wir
sind sofort davon ist der laden ich war
vorher noch nie also wir mal gespannt
also auch in der umgebung ich hatte auch
niemals gedacht dass hier sein laden
kommt sieht irgendwie so nach boden aus
[Musik]
obwohl davor noch stellen
für mich einmal
den cheeseburger 130 kann
[Musik]
ganz neu ist das so
deshalb wird
das hat mir verboten
wenn man schon bestellt
manchmal angespannt
so leisten also bürger ist da doch gut
aus oder
[Musik]
heute vor allem wieso es ist eigentlich
echt lecker wurde mir empfohlen das ist
reza mario und der bürger sieht super so
weit kommen und mein staubsauger wischt
geraden das badezimmer also ich habe ja
schon gesagt er hat auch eine funktion
und vielleicht kann man das jetzt hier
sehen
es wird gerade kräftig gewischt das ist
ein bisschen schwer zu erkennen weil es
jetzt so hell ist hier kann man ganz gut
diese spur sehen ja soweit ich bin
wieder zurück und ich habe noch gar kein
fast gemacht werden wir auf also um
ehrlich zu sein nämlich das ganze jetzt
schon einen tag später auf ich weiß ich
bin irgendwie manchmal so ich habe das
video gedreht habe probiert und denkt an
so ok fertig aber es ist ja nicht so ich
muss hier noch was dazu sagen weil ich
sehr sehr wichtig also erstmal sich
sagen wir haben für zwei bürger -
ungefähr 23 euro bezahlt was vollkommen
okay ist das heißt wir haben ein
durchschnittspreis von 1 50 euro pro
menü ich würde mal sagen das absolut
standard führenden burger weil man hier
mittags halten burger essen gehen möchte
eventuell sogar etwas unter dem
durchschnitt wobei man auch sagen muss
die lage ist halt schon relativ
außerhalb und nicht im zentrum es hat
wirklich sehr frisch geschmeckt also ich
bin mir auch sicher dass alles frisch
war und so und ja es war ein richtig
richtig guter bürger dann stellt sich
natürlich immer die frage okay ist das
jetzt der allerbeste den man hier
fliegen kann
ich würde auch mal sagen dass ich schon
öfter mal burger gegessen habe die
ähnlich gut geschmeckt haben auch hier
so in der stadt und so trotzdem kann man
darauf jedenfalls nichts falsch machen
vielleicht sehen die jungs das ja
manchmal undercover getestet und das war
wirklich sehr lecker also macht weiter
so ich hoffe das war okay viele fragen
ja ja alex wieso fragst du nicht ob du
dann da mal probieren kannst so dass du
nicht an der kammer film muss und darum
habe ich auch noch kurz eine antwort und
zwar sollen die leuchte ist ja gar nicht
merken dass ich das probiere bei wenn da
so ein youtuber oder fernsehen kommt
dann gibt man sich ja mühe damit es gut
schmeckt und wir wollen ja halt normale
bedingungen haben das mit dem video
schreibt gerne ideen für weitere
restaurant fest in die kommentare
haut rein